Lake Mead sitting almost eight feet
higher today than it did this time last
year and Rangers anticipating another 20
to 25 feet just by the end of the summer
and now with millions of dollars in new
funding the park service is starting to
prepare for the next time the water
drops critically low 8 news now reporter
Ryan Matthey shows us what it could mean
[Music]
that's how high the water was 92 year
old Betty grippintock and her husband
purchased the Las Vegas Boat Harbor in
the 50s the publicity was so bad that
people thought there wasn't any place to
boat with the last two summers she says
have been the most brutal amid
historically low water levels her son
Bob now the co-owner says when water's
down customers don't always stick around
we have to move anchors and move things
and then and our costs is much greater
at that time and they're expecting
Better Business this summer because of
the rise here on Lake Mead but as you
can see where water was just a couple
years ago that rise may not last forever
now federal dollars being used to
anticipate the next drop pouring
concrete if you really get down to it
it's that simple what the Lake Mead
Recreation Area Acting Superintendent
Mike Gautier says may extend the five
boat launch ramps on Lake Mead now as
Democratic Nevada senator Jackie Rosen
says 32 million dollars in disaster
supplemental funding is secured it's
awarded to Regions with severe economic
distress from natural disasters in 2021
and 22. as the water goes down there's
actually Cliffs below so you can't
really continue to build boat ramps in
so then you have to ask the question
well do you build a node a road to a new
place and maybe design a ramp there
that'll work better at a lower elevation
that possibility what he says will come
from geologic and engineering studies
they can now afford but the work of
extending itself may be years away when
it drops that's when you can actually
start building stuff because you can't
really build stuff when the water is up
so we want to be prepared and that's
what we're going to use some of that
money for
so we can tell you right now Rangers do
anticipate keeping all five of those
boat launches open throughout the end of
the calendar year at least for now